um I have a question that someone put in
the Super Chat
um it's a little different than the
church topic but if um if our nation was
in Wartime do you they really think men
do they think men would really sign up
to protect their nation and women based
on how they are mistreated demonized and
not appreciated
could you say that again if our nation
was in Wartime do you think that men
would sign up to protect their nation
and women based on how they are
mistreated demonized and not appreciated
today if we yeah
well I think most yeah most men are
overweight too so I think we're in
trouble next War I think men I think the
men of nowadays are the softest yeah I
agree you know they're the most
effeminate I don't know what China and
Russia must be looking at us like yeah
yeah they must be laughing like these
are the guys that you got yeah you know
what I mean I don't care they're not
scared of the world is not scared not
when guys are dying their hair green and
putting saying I'm asexual and I'm
non-binary it's like asexual things
doesn't want to have sex doesn't mean
yeah what what guy's saying that
no no some people actually don't want to
have sex a lot of Christian men yeah but
that's not because they don't want to
it's because they understand that in
order to the priests like the priests
and the fathers are they not that's not
someone signing up to go to war he's
saying like what's what's
men are treated as disposable like women
are not good to men in this society and
one out of three men haven't had sex in
the past year and historically men
became for women so they would become
something because they were motivated to
provide for their family yeah but now
they have no woman to provide for so
they're addicted to corn and video games
because they they're hopeless because
nowadays the average woman doesn't look
at the average man because the dating
Market is so inflated because of birth
control that we're sleeping with a
smaller and smaller and smaller
percentage of guys you want a guy that's
over six foot fifteen percent of guys
you want a guy that's in the top half of
Attraction cut it in half you want a guy
that's in the top half of income cut
that in half and so dating app data
shows that we swipe between five to
twenty percent of the time they get
eighty percent of the matches and so
it's like these guys have no purpose
so what why are they going to fight for
our country I would say for society to
survive men have to have a purpose if
men feel like in the society they don't
have a purpose I think you are going to
see the decline of the West Indies women
have to make you make that purpose for
men that do we have to make you have the
to some degree yeah yeah but I also I
also believe that men are distracted
more nowadays there's more distraction
literally they've got grown ass men
playing computer games every single
[__] day sorry in my language but
it's just like
it really like is this your purpose like
you're gonna just play games all day
like where's the purpose all day well
and and
the problem is that
women like the average woman doesn't get
with the average guy because she's
sleeping with the top guy that's never
gonna wife her and so and and and and
typically before we had to prioritize
other things outside of looks like we
had to otherwise we'd get pregnant by by
the Chad right and he's gonna leave
because you know he gets all the women
he's not going to provide so he had to
prioritize a provider but with birth
control it allows us to sleep with the
smaller and smaller percentage of men
and not prioritize the other side of it
and then you know we roll up at 30 35
you know running out of time to have
kids saying take me now
and it's like to the average guy yeah
like because and we deny them in our 20
this is what men are complaining about
average guy average guy was that dude at
school that you were at school with that
you know that I'm not an average guy but
I'm saying the average guy now so 45
45k average looking yeah yeah so what
I'm saying is every time so when the
girls been ran through popping her pills
as she goes back to the average guy is
the average guy taking her
the issue the issue is that it only
benefits women and so there's a large
there's a large there's a there's a
large portion of Mana that are very
frustrated because they think that the
woman wants to marry them they think the
woman is excited to be with them when
really she misses her at her ex from
like three exes ago they get married she
gets the kids she wants then she starts
being a thought again like Sierra right
or or she stops having sex with him
again you didn't see I mean as a mother
and a wife you're going to be twerking
on top of a car her husband is happy
he's not working but but the point is
see it's this is funny it's like women
always excuse women it's bad behavior
you're in the church you really think
that's acceptable
okay so then don't excuse it okay her
husband knew where she came from
yeah we're talking about her behavior
it's always a butt and then the men
allow it this is the same argument she's
been the same from the does she ever
change yeah
she claimed she claimed she claimed
uh Russell Wilson and then you can kind
of see us slide him back to us wait wait
wait yeah she claimed one she claimed to
have changed when she was about to get
married so she waited till she was
married to have sex yeah are you Sierra
as an example because it's a perfect
example of what happens all the time in
a celebrity she dates the future she
dates the bad boys then she's thinking
Hmm I need to get married soon I'm
running out of time let me say I've
gotten right with God same thing with
Megan good I've gotten right with god
um so I can get a husband the husband
thinks she's changed when really she
feels like she's settling for him and
she really wants the guy from the past
and you can see this because she doesn't
respect him enough to not twerk on a car
like she doesn't like whereas the other
guy like the other would have been like
what the [__] are you doing yeah and
it's it's on the guys too because they
allow it like I'm with you Russell
Wilson yeah but the point is that she's
disrespecting him because she doesn't
think that that's the best she could
have done she doesn't view him as like
really women don't respect guys like
that
they'll say it but in their actions
you'll see whether or not they respect
guys like that see there's okay there
are certain women that when they get
with a guy you know that she respects
him and she would never do half of the
things that she would do with a with the
other guy that you've seen her with
because she doesn't respect that guy
she's afraid to lose him right and
that's that's how you can tell because
like she's doing all this wild [__]
she's not afraid to lose him no just
like some guys some guys some guys don't
cheat because they're afraid to lose the
girl but I think all those standards
from like since we're talking about
Sarah I think all those standards was
more from Russell like he was the one
that wanted to wait till marriage and
she just went onto his page because she
liked him yeah so he thought she was
getting on his program and she was it
was just an act so what are they getting
divorced there what's happening
yeah she was actually Russell Wilson is
a simp yeah it's the same thing with
Will Smith
yeah like she she dates Tupac and
continuously talks about him to the
point where her own daughter is writing
a letter
like that's I mean is she afraid to lose
well I mean
if this is happening to celebrities the
top men that women like I I would date
well like I think everyone in this room
would date Will Smith right
okay you understand what I'm saying that
this is happening to top guys what does
that mean for the average guy and so
these guys get married at 30 thinking
that this girl is excited to be with
them but she's not she just wants kids
she wants kids in the bits of safety
yeah but then there's some I mean I mean
maybe if for the for the for the hoes
yeah but then
I don't I don't think a lot of girls are
out here hovering around and being
running through I think most girls
unless they're lying but I think most
girls are you know trying to keep their
body count down and find that man so I
think if you if you're not a hoe and you
marry someone I don't I don't I think it
depends if you're already like I don't
care whatever then if that was the case
then you'd find more uh women okay so I
I pulled I pulled I pulled my audience
and I said what do you think the average
body count is for a 20 year old woman in
2022 yeah the the highest answer was 10
to 20 for a 20 year old woman 20 years
of age yeah and uh in the UK
i i people are from here
no they're the the audience is mixed
right um what's the average body count
of a 25 year old woman
um 45 said over 20.
and then I said what do you think the
average body count is a third of the
average body count of a 30 year old
woman is in 2022 34 said 30 plus
so if women are keeping it low I I think
the men would would agree but they're
not like
I would say love is less than five
because when you when you look at when
you look at bonding statistics like like
that's when it switches for women so the
women answer that men answer the poll or
anyone anyone answered yeah both men and
women oh okay so if we said one yeah
it's it's both it's both and so like I
would say under five would be low Based
on data because like women lose their
you start to see repercussions for
sleeping around after five partners
because the average like the average
if a woman gets married and she's only
had sex with one person that she has an
80 chance of a happy marriage if she
slept with more than five it goes down
to 25 so that's when you start to see
the repercussions so like women aren't
keeping their body counts low okay and
plus this is the one of the reasons why
we know why women lie about their body
count
a man a man will promote his body count
yeah one more lie about her yeah but can
I ask is there anything different like
between say a woman today
and a woman let's say in the 50s like
psychologically it like is there any
loads yeah there's less issues of Shame
guilt societal expectations the risk of
pregnancy no so what I'm sorry let me
explain that if you brought a 1950s
woman into today's society
would she not behave the same way as the
women behave today she would like women
in the 1950s had cookbooks they were
taught they needed men and they worked
to get a man where a woman today just
exists they're told not to cook
I don't cook I don't clean that that's
like our grandparents working yes our
grandparents worked through cheating
like there are so many stories they they
were in it through thick and thin were
women modern women first sign of
cheating they leave it could be one time
thing he could bring it to you she's
leaving she's out and she's taken half
right 1950s he could have a whole side
chick across town she's working it out
with her husband it was just a different
I'm not saying mentality it was it was
women had consequences back then so they
acted accordingly nowadays we took away
all the consequences from women so they
act accordingly but this is the thing
like you keep saying we whereas I I give
men like the Commendation when I know
it's men who have done this like it's
men who basically built our nation who
fought for us it is men if we are going
to be honest it is men who are in power
and so at the same time very small
percentage of me that's not necessarily
true women make 70 to 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions so you can't
necessarily say that we're not in power
a very small right I mean like it makes
the laws like in government
ripe a woman vote
and women and women are like they win
elections there's more women than men
and if they're and if you're you're
saying men are the ones in power it's a
very small percentage of men that you're
talking about you're talking about like
one percent of the world's population
saying oh men are in power it's like
there's one percent of like the
population that are in power and they
they happen to be men but it doesn't
mean I mean men in general are like that
are in power no no I'm not saying that
I'm just saying those specific Elite men
are the ones who are actually setting
Society but the way you guys have
explained it they're setting it based on
what um can keep them in power which is
basically women is how you guys
evaluated yes because I mean how did
they get into power they sold a lot of
[__] like actually I'm thinking of like
Jeff Bezos Mark Zuckerberg they had
they had to get used women to get there
basically I want to say use it wasn't a
statistic for Consumer there at what
percentage of a consumer do women
um they own two I think it's two-thirds
two-thirds the Consumer Debt so even
though we make less money we spend more
um
baby shopping and I think this all the
time because there will be girls that I
know make less than me and I'm like how
[__] I'm like because I can't afford
that so I don't know what the hell
you're doing when I was in a
relationship pay for it there was an
Amazon delivery nearly every week at the
door I was just like what you bought
something again oh but I needed it
um I'm gonna Read Super